best friends whatever while something on
my face
hi everybody its senior editor Kevin van
ORD standing in for reviewer nathan ba
to tell you about jazzpunk the promise
of getting deluge by weirdness awaits
your every move in jazzpunk a cartoony
cyberpunk first-person adventure that
attempts to shoehorn as many funny
moments as possible into its two-hour
length this off-the-wall journey does
not follow a straight line from start to
finish however since every retro
futurists etting you explore is riddled
with crazy secrets to discover oh good
boobs ah jazz punks warped version of
the special agent life begins with its
silent protagonist Polly Blanc being
mailed through customs in a human-shaped
suitcase and deposited on the doorstep
of a top-secret espionage agency that's
based out of an abandoned subway car if
the brain warping neons psychedelic
intro doesn't make you feel like you've
been drugged the ebb and flow of the
many humorous absurdities layered thick
throughout the peculiar opening moments
certainly will
from there the wild ride takes a more
overt turn towards the bizarre when your
director hands you a prescription bottle
of mysterious pills to take in order to
be quote-unquote transported to your
first mission yeah that's all just in
the first minute or so
the surreal missions that follow have
you degaussing and smuggling pigeons
extracting mechanical organs from sushi
loving Cowboys cross-dressing for a
vacation rendezvous briefcase swap
murdering a bionic Pig with a six string
guitar and even photocopying your
backside it's all excessively bizarre
which is a huge part of the fun you
never know what crazy thing you'll
encounter next and being diligent in
poking around every nook and cranny
rewards you with a slew of hilarious
secrets and gags overcoming obstacles in
your way and sniffing out the path ahead
isn't particularly challenging though
the often unusual nature of the many
tasks you have to complete to progress
makes them highly entertaining to fiddle
through experimenting to see what
happens when you interact with an object
or test out some new gizmo you've
acquired on an unwitting test subject
is often rewarding on its own humor is
the heart of this demented adventure and
it's hard not to chuckle a bit when
you're spraying liquid cheese into the
mouth of a bespectacled gentleman or
beheading pepperoni and cheese zombies
with the giant pizza cutter the
situations you find yourself in from one
moment to the next row increasingly
outrageous the further you push not all
of the gags hit the mark though and the
laughs worthy mileage you get will
depend in part on your amusement
threshold for constant wisecracks
Jakub retro themes minigames modeled
after classics from the 8-bit and 16-bit
eras throw added variety into this crazy
concoction they're entertaining asides
that break up the gag heavy exploration
and minor puzzle elements though
jazzpunk leans on these diversions too
heavily at times but by the time you're
playing mini-golf and racing gravy boats
towards the final stretches the
substance and humor have wanes
considerably
it's an odd shift considering the
overall level of ingenious creativity
thrown in elsewhere the bonus
multiplayer mode wedding-cake is one big
exception however having a let's get
married
deathmatch where you engage opponents
and blast them with champagne corks good
time baby
one spring even if the humor doesn't
always click and the depth can be light
at moments jazzpunk stylish presentation
and great backing soundtrack set a slick
atmosphere the cool vibe inspires the
need to stick around in its peculiar
world a bit longer jazzpunk is an
enthusiastic attempt to answer the
question of just how much weirdness can
you possibly cram into a few hours of
gaming and in that endeavor it's a great
achievement
you